olá e aí galera to voltando bom vocês
olha aqui bom então eu tava pensando que
odeio senhorzinho a gerar um dia da sua
vez se falou assim a fé no ps esse é meu
amigo lucas está não queria ser amiga
ludicamente um amigo look o coração das
pessoas muito em baixo de um ai eu gosto
de fulano ao corte fuma mellodi citrano
aí sicrano um ano no caso
nunca gosto de você nunca na verdade a
culpa não é de coração vou seguir face à
então bordo
ae a culpa do meu coração o trabalho com
a sob a sangue não é escolher quer que
você goste ou não goste não paulo com 41
com a renovação é um amigo das artérias
da veia do sangue da vida jesus nem meu
hum eu cheguei a uma conclusão
sabe por que as pessoas se vejam o que
elas pensam assim cara eu te amo tanto
que eu sou capaz de passar mesmo é o
cuspe na boca a pessoa goste de se
beijar porque ela se ama nelas foi um
sacrifício a fire chique liga nenê na
boca em fá lo ei paga um sorvete a
ganhar na boca
e é por isso que eu sou um bom ator
ai ai
josé antonio chang e ii com isso um dia
você está viajando
o que eu quero agora vem dizer que não
posso me chamais chandon agora é aceitar
mission um calafrio nem eu vá e quando
faltará primeiro mal mas também a lançar
eu capricho meu descrição saltado não
também jantou e meio do pedal tomando
banho toda vez que eu tomo banho fellini
é uma hora você ser brando tudo você
fica rosa ou vermelho amores ao copo já
desonera equipas que tomar anabolizante
uma doença infecciosa que pode se tornar
o horizonte parece os carros ao pois é
que ela é esse é o velho da impressão de
sobrancelha grossa
meu nariz de batata meu lado é grosso ea
disciplina cara meu cabelo em caixa e
acabei nem caixa eu me acho tão feio meu
irmão abel
ainda bem que eu engraçado como as
coisas vão dar certo é uma merda
o problema é quando você planeja você
pensa você com e quando não dá certo é
um fracasso seu todo o dia de hoje
estava estudando claro que clown palhaço
o palhaço ele trabalha com um fracasso o
fracasso de engraçado os outros por isso
agora eu sou um palhaço porque o meu
fracasso pode ser engraçado pra você a
partir de hoje tudo que terra da minha
vida eu sei que ditava a maioria das
finanças do japão consiga 60 dias que
você acha o encontro marcado com um
racha com você né e tb livro mas agora a
partir de hoje tudo deu errado eu vou
contar pra vocês e vocês vão rir de mim
vou ficar muito feliz não vou ficar
muito feliz por vocês ficarem felizes
por mim tá bom a gente já sabe que toda
vez que eu boto vídeo que você explica
não gosto eu fico muito feliz
e quando cheguei me move parque beleza a
quando especificou gostei eu fico feliz
e faça outro vídeo toda vez que tem
muito gosto em um vídeo fico muito feliz
aí eu filmo inserir toda vez eu fico
feliz eu faço outro vídeo quando faço
vídeo você fica muito feliz aí fez meu
deus as pessoas tão feliz acho que eu
vou fazer outro virtual faz outro vídeo
se você clicar em gostei
aqui no botão aqui embaixo e gostei aí
eu vou ficar muito feliz
aí eu estou muito feliz e faz o outro
vídeo você foi infeliz e vai virar um
ciclo vicioso da felicidade e todos nós
vamos ficar feliz para sempre trabalhado
com clicando gostei
já josé ramón oitava semana santa como
ele seria na semana santa que ele está
falando agora quer saber o que você está
fazendo agora neste momento que você
está assistindo o vídeo como aqui em
baixo se você está inscrito no canal
olha você não sabe o que está perdendo é
é um monte de primeira qualidade eu sou
melhor cada show muito bom diz algo
muito engraçado você não sabe que tem
papel de mimi sério que é obrigado você
escutar todos nas minhas metas todos os
dias eu gosto muito de você pode não
saber quando fiquei buscar o céu segue
eu sou meu coração cada beijo no coração
do filho
eu acho que você está